at the end of the speech uh joe said go
get him that was the big finish of the
thing and it became unclear to people
what he meant by that because uh
normally it's you know god bless america
okay i'm out of here go get
all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
go get him
what did he mean by that even nbc
the propagandist at nbc even they were a
little confused by what that meant
i also think there was a strange moment
at the end where he said go get him that
was audible to the audience
and we're not quite sure what he means i
think he's talking about vladimir putin
and the bad guys over there but
it was an ad-lib that
kind of yeah normally his clothes god
bless god bless you that was soldiers i
think he was trying to buck up america
and say we're strong the state of the
union is strong get out there and you
know
remember that we are strong as americans
by the way
don't worry guys he just said some
random statement at the end uh but no
this is what he meant because they they
carry water for him right they carry
water for the administration i think he
met vladimir putin and the bad guys
sounds like a band in brooklyn in 1987
doesn't it vlad putin and the bad guys
putin and the bad guys they're a real
hipster band it's like what did he mean
by that he just blurted outside did he
mean go get him like go kill putin
let's get the nuclear war going like
what is he actually talking about
doesn't matter nobody knows he must mean
this because he's obviously not having
some sort of mental breakdown
then this morning this one's from this
morning although there was plenty of
stuff going on last night jen sake the
white house press secretary she had a an
accidental slip up maybe even two slip
ups here i believe this is from cnn
take a look you know i was at the state
department the president was the vice
president the last time russia invaded
ukraine this is a pattern of horror from
this president from president putin and
from the cronies around him
all right so first off this is a pattern
of horror from this presidency she fixed
that okay we all misspeak sometimes fine
but uh lady i think you accidentally
said the quiet part owl out there yeah
there's a pattern here
putin seems to invade on biden's watch
he was the vp
when putin did it last time now he's the
p he was vp now he's p you see what's
going on here there is a pattern there
that putin does bad things when he
thinks that we have incompetent people
who don't actually live up to their
words and set their red lines and set
order in the world
then he does some bad stuff when we've
got those type of people involved and
guys remind me i can't remember i'm
thinking about this one it's driving me
crazy there was a guy who was president
uh for four years in between when uh
when biden was vp and when he was p
do you have any recollection of who that
was
any of you guys he was
he was
yes orange man remember orange man
scary racist white supremacist orange
man for some reason that pattern that
sake is talking about the pattern was
broken during orange man
i don't know i don't have my abacus here
to figure it all out but something seems
weird about that uh there was more from
nvc though uh stephanie rule
actually acknowledged that
biden's inflation crisis is a problem
although there's a little little
trickery that she does right up top
which we'll get to take a look president
biden has a complicated economic story
to tell while he has some very big wins
six and a half million jobs created
unemployment now down to four percent
and household savings hitting a record
high as we come out of the pandemic
those are very big wins unfortunately
for this administration they're
discounted because the inflation that
we're facing right now is a huge problem
for the american people we see it all
over the place and it's not going to get
any better anytime soon because of the
situation in ukraine now it's no
surprise the gop's response was
hammering inflation over and over but
frankly they didn't even need to do that
the american people are feeling it every
single day it's what they're talking
about at their kitchen tables and it's
what's causing a problem in approval
ratings for president biden 6.5 million
new jobs now of course she doesn't tell
you that it's because they locked
everybody down that the jobs went up
this year as things sort of opened up
which is exactly what the next number
that she gave was that unemployment is
less than it was last year which is the
exact same thing so even when they're
trying to tell you something true that
we all have no we all know about this
unemployment uh this inflation problem
like they still sort of lie in the way
that they frame it okay is what it is
chuck todd who uh is another nbc guy uh
he really wanted uh joe to
talk more about ukraine we put it this
way in in some ways
for the sake of the ukrainians i hope we
don't say it didn't you know i hope we
say oh
it was about right but i fear
this is going to feel like a speech that
didn't age well because of the lack of i
thought he'd spend more time in ukraine
spend a little more time
explaining why it is our fight as you
said good versus evil explain what a
little bit more and a little bit of the
history of the defense of europe and a
little bit of how why we're in this
position why we have these alliances
what what it all means
and
it just felt like an abrupt end
after the 12 minutes of that and it felt
like boy we could have had more there
was more to say i think there was more
that the public would have and then it
turned look i do think he accomplished
two
important pieces of politics
saying the phrases secure our borders
and fund our police
there are a lot of vulnerable democrats
and a lot of uh house and senate races
that are relieved to hear the leader of
the democratic party say those two
phrases
okay first off more time on ukraine the
whole beginning the whole heart of this
thing was about ukraine and basically
threatening russia okay that's what it
was that's not me defending russia you
can't just attack another sovereign
nation okay russia bad right now putin
not the good guy uh but more time chuck
do you know that this was the american
state of the union what is the state of
our union what is the situation that we
got going right now and if you ask the
average person who's watching inflation
grow uh go up who's watching critical
race theory in their kids schools and
the mass and all the stuff where do you
think ukraine fits into this that is not
to say it is not uh important to do what
we can to help western democracies
and we can have all sorts of discussions
about that which we don't do
particularly well but in the state of
our union that thing is not on the top
ten list and he spent most of the time
talking about it